reformas Ese fue el anuncio del
presidente francés Emmanuel macron en su
discurso anual de nochevieja desde el
palacio del Eliseo el mandatario
prometió una profunda reforma
institucional y la controversial reforma
de las pensiones que pretende llevar la
edad de jubilación a los 65 años
este año si será el de una reforma de
las pensiones que pretende equilibrar
nuestro sistema para las próximas
décadas Tenemos que trabajar más este
sentido de la Reforma del seguro de
desempleo también en el sentido de esta
reforma en la que el gobierno los
interlocutores sociales y el parlamento
trabajarán para poner en marcha las
normas que se aplicarán a partir de
finales de 2023
también hizo referencia en su alocución
a los distintos retos que plantea la
guerra en Ucrania prometiendo seguir
apoyando aquí f en clave militar Y
apelando al trabajo conjunto del bloque
europeo
mis queridos compatriotas quiero decir
aquí y esta noche que en vuestro nombre
a nuestros amigos ucranianos los
respetamos y los admiramos su lucha por
defender sus naciones heroica y nos
inspira y en el próximo año estaremos a
su lado sin falta los ayudaremos a
alcanzar la victoria y trabajaremos
juntos para construir una paz justa y
duradera cuenten con Francia cuenten con
Europa
macrón compartió los desafíos para su
país derivados de la invasión rusa
Ucrania la crisis energética alimentaria
estando a los franceses ahorrar en
energía
en 2023 Tendremos que consolidar paso a
paso nuestra independencia energética
económica social Industrial financiera y
estratégica ya fortalecer Nuestra fuerza
del alma
el presidente galo apeló a reforzar
militarmente las fronteras europeas y
combatir así la migración de esta forma
despide el año Emanuel macan culminando
con un llamado a la unidad nacional